pour être encore très précis je venais
le matin de chez moi avec mon arme à la
ceinture et je repartais le soir chez
moi avec mon arme à la ceinture
il m'est arrivé pour m'entretenir parce
que je considère pas qu'elle s'est pas
rien de porter une arme
c'est une responsabilité qu on vous
confie aussi que ce soit nous sommes
d'accord et donc il m'est arrivé de
pouvoir m'exercer avec des gens qui sont
je pense les plus compétents et les plus
aptes à vous enseigner un certain nombre
de choses et ce sont les personnels du
gspr et donc j'ai pu aller à plusieurs
reprises m'entraîner avec eux dans un
stand de tir qui est pas loin de paris
et j'ai pu me perfectionner
on va dire dans le maniement des armes
et donc j'ai pu partir du moment où vous
allez tirer que j'espère comment
s'organise une séance de tir les
policiers et gendarmes du j'espère
arrive à l'elysée non je veux juste
préciser ils arrivent avec leurs armes à
l'elysée - le matin j'arrive avec mon
ancienne séance à 10 heures je vais pas
aller mettre mon arme au coffre en
disant je vais attendre 10 heures pour
les récupérer donc je veux plus avoir
mon arme à la ceinture dans l'enceinte
du palais de l'elysée ok d'accord deux
fois je pense mais me